very excited to give this talk actually
so uh
thanks for coming to this
um so one of the things i do in my spare
time besides biking is i play in a
concert band i play trombone and uh one
of the things in in band is sometimes
you play a piece of music known as a
tone poem and usually what this is is
it's a piece of music that is inspired
by something maybe non-musical like
maybe a painting or something so you
take a painting and then there's a piece
of music inspired by that you play the
music okay so um this talk in some sense
is that i'm going to be using the
language of python to describe something
that's
well really not python well you'll see
okay so it's it's
that's kind of the spirit of it uh and
then the other thing with biking there's
a certain danger of going biking at
about 5 a.m so about a year and a half
ago i hit a deer in the face while
riding my road bike
and ended up breaking my wrist and two
fingers in opposite hands um that's not
the deer by the way the deer as far as i
know is uninjured this is um
the picture you see there is probably
from a coyote
not far from where i actually hit a deer
actually this is a the same bike path
but
um there's a certain problem with having
an accident like that which is it makes
life very difficult for somebody that
likes live typing and live coding and
things like that right you know it's
it's like this is this is definitely
going to put a damper on things
and so um
that's the not typing part of the talk
um
i'm actually not it's not about the
typing module sorry about that okay so
um so having having this accident um
i kind of spent some time looking at
some different things um you know
learning about some new stuff and the
talk is kind of inspired by that so
so
one of the things i was thinking about
with the accident is i'm really glad i
didn't hit a deer with antlers
and i'm really glad i didn't hit a deer
with antlers guarded by another deer
with antlers this would have been a
really bad situation but this idea of
pears is actually something that comes
up a lot in programming right we think
of like pairs of
numbers for like math operations uh alu
on a cpu takes pairs of inputs
everybody's favorite data structure you
know the python dictionary you got keys
and values it's pairs right so
uh left and right first and second pairs
are are sort of fundamental and actually
a lot of like computing right we use
these all the time
and
one kind of interesting exercise you can
do is restrict yourself to only
programming with pairs okay this is a
new style guide you're not actually
allowed to use python lists or
dictionaries or sets or anything like
that the only thing you can use are
pairs
and you can challenge yourself to make
data structures so what a list might
look like is something like this it's
consistent of pairs
and then you have a lot of fun writing
algorithms on this like computing the
length or maybe you want to practice
recursion or maybe you really like
reversing linked lists because you have
a goal of getting a job playing foosball
somewhere okay so there's all sorts of
things that you can do with this but
frankly um
that's not really that interesting i
mean well it's kind of interesting but
nobody really cares about implementing
linked lists or reversing
reversing linked lists so
a different a different line of thought
that you might have
is all of the different ways that you
might implement a pair
i don't know do you use a tuple
do you use a list
maybe a dictionary a class
a class with slots maybe you like data
class like data classes definitely or
named tuples or a classic named tuple or
a third-party package or some crazy
lambda function thing there's gonna be a
quiz on this code later by the way so
um but you might go through that and
again it's it's like okay you know we
could have a battle about the you know
the best way to implement a pair you
know whether a data class or a tuple or
something like that but honestly nobody
really cares about that
and here's why okay so so imagine you
have some object okay this is a pair
a pair of numbers
what do we actually care about here is
it do we care about the internals or or
do we care about something else and what
we really care about is whether we can
split it apart again kind of the
essential property of a pair is that you
can split it
first element second element i'm going
to use f and s for first and second here
so
so
that is sort of the property we are
about
and as long as we have that we sort of
don't care
how the thing is implemented right i
mean you could have a pair that uses
tuples or you could have a pair that
uses dictionaries and
you know and it's fine this is something
that we're all familiar with in python i
mean this is you know duct typing kind
of stuff you know it's interfaces as
long as something has the interface
you don't really care what it is
okay so
so we're all familiar with that but
there's a a different line of thinking
on this okay so so
here's here's kind of a kind of a
flipped question okay i mean we know
that something is a pair
based on what it has the interface right
but do pairs know that they're paired
kind of a weird question so here's
scenario let's say let's say you have a
pair let's say you have a class that you
definitely know implements a pair
but then you have some other class plu
or something i don't know what blue is
but
you can create a blue object
one two
and you can ask a question is that a
pair or not and i would hope that the
answer is i have no idea okay i mean plu
is something we don't know what that is
it's not inheriting from pair it's just
some random thing so we really don't
know
but
suppose that there was some function
unknown to us we don't know anything
about the internals to this okay so we
we this has been provided from somewhere
that that takes a plew and produces a
pair okay so there's some way
to go from blue to pear
does that make blue into a pair is that
does that does that make it a pair
and again the answer is
not really sure i mean without knowing
any details about a i can't i wouldn't
be able to say for certain i mean maybe
this is some other thing that's doing
that's producing a pair so i don't you
know i honestly don't i honestly don't
know
and
it does kind of raise this question of
what would the requirements be i mean if
plu were a pair
i would have to retain this ability to
kind of split it apart right i mean i
would have to be able to get to the one
and the two and i just don't know
whether i can do that um
i know that if i i know that with this a
i can convert it
i can produce this pair like object
right i mean i can produce a pair type
of some kind and i can split that but i
just have no guarantee what it's going
to do right i mean maybe i do that and i
get some
different values out of it and then it's
like no i don't i don't know what that
is
but
um
if i were to be able to do this like
let's say it actually worked
okay create a blue
i adapt it and then i get one and two
um
i might be able to argue that actually
blue is a pair and it doesn't even know
that it's a pair okay so it like maybe
it's int it's like yeah i can use that
as a pair because i can adapt it
basically
you know i could i can convert it to p
and then i could use f and s and then
every everywhere i wanted to i could use
plus a pair
so it's kind of a it's kind of a strange
line of thinking but it sort of leads to
this rule that if something can be
adapted into a duck then it's a duck
and you can start playing games like
this you can start thinking it's like oh
i can adapt things and so there's all
sorts of ways you can convert tuple to
dictionary and dictionaries to tuples
and classes to dictionaries and classes
to tuples and
we do this all the time in programming
it's like adaption you know adaptive
pattern and stuff like that it's it's
it's how to make a small program into a
huge program and all you know that that
kind of stuff been and eventually you'll
sort of tire of this um
this game of adapting but then you might
start to ask um
like deeper questions okay this is a
more interesting question is there a
perfect implementation of a picture
this is how one starts to get into big
arguments at work right you know the
bike shedding argument that's like what
is the perfect implementation and so
suppose that aliens came down from space
and they presented a pair of like this
pip install pair okay so we have aliens
presenting a pair to us
and there's a claim on it a pair perfect
for humans okay bold claim and we're
going to be very skeptical of this and
ask questions like what do you mean
perfect for perfect for humans like what
do you mean perfection what are you
talking about
and
the the
idea that that actually leads to kind of
an interesting thought experiment
actually um
what would it mean to have a perfect
implementation of something
not just say that it's perfect i mean
the aliens would just say look at it
it's perfect and it's like well that's
not gonna fly okay so
how would you prove this well one of the
ways that you might
investigate that is you might make a
claim that any kind of inferior pair
could be upgraded into the perfect one
you could adapt it like you could
basically say yeah okay using tuples but
you know we we we're going to do this
more perfect thing
and so you could take all of the kind of
lesser pairs and adapt it
but then somebody's going to ask um
well couldn't you go the other way
like couldn't the perfect pair be
downgraded into a lesser perfect one in
some way and then we're going to have
this argument again about which is the
perfect pair and so clearly
this is never ever going to be allowed i
mean if this perfect pair is perfect
it is ever never going to be able to be
downgraded now i have no idea how this
is going to be implemented i mean i'm
not even sure raymond hettinger knows
how to implement something like this but
the gist of it
is that this perfect pair would only be
adapted into itself
that's the only thing it would ever
allow it's like the perfect narcissistic
pair in fact the arrow is even orange
okay so
um there's sort of this limit
of perfection you know it's like okay
that's kind of a weird concept you've
got this perfect thing
that only adapts to itself
but
but what if you know nothing at all okay
so here's so so let's say aliens come
down they present this thing to you
and
they just tell you documentation just
look at it
okay we don't know what it is okay you
you're presented with this object
um alien object you don't know what it
is can you make any claim about it and
i don't you know i don't know just
looking at it um maybe you can do things
like wave your hand at it or
stare at it or something like that maybe
in the process of waving your hand at it
two things pop out of
it and now you can ask this question
it's like okay is that a pair
maybe
it was one thing and now two things
right i don't know split split apart
and
that line of thinking again kind of
takes you back to like what is the
essential thing that is going on with
pears here is it um
is it the thing
or is it the arrows
the arrows in some sense are giving its
shape right it's the the arrows are sort
of defining like the deck that it's
splitting apart
and so
instead of talking about pairs i
actually want to talk about arrows for a
second so let's say you have an arrow
what is this even talking about okay
what like what are we what are we even
talking about with an arrow is this like
an input to a function is it an output
of a function is this a value of some
kind
is it a type and of course you know that
it's a type because you saw the title of
the talk it said types right so at some
point i was going to talk about types
okay so
so let's explore this a little bit okay
so imagine an arrow is i don't know it's
something coming out of somewhere okay
and it has a has a type attached to it
and as programmers
you know we're familiar with concepts of
types you know we have int and bool and
float and string and so forth and and
you know being sort of a systems
programmer myself i'm thinking a lot
about hardware you know it's like oh
this is 32-bit this is 64-bit and
i gotta i gotta you know encode this and
think about little endian and all this
stuff so so there's there's this concept
of concept of types but
this is not
really the interesting thing with types
int is not interesting i mean what's
what's interesting is when the types
start to pair up
and we're now we're back at the
beginning a pair
and a pair of pairs okay things like
that like what is going on if you start
messing around with types like pairs of
types combinations of types and so forth
and so i'm going to kind of kind of go
through a few little thought experiments
concerning combinations of types so so
and pairing of type so imagine you have
a
you have a pair of ties
pair a b
is that the same as pair ba
like if i just switch the types around
and
i think most
rational programmers actually would look
at that and say no
no that's not gonna no like an inch a
float is not the same as a float in an
end i mean a type checker is going to
blow that up and
so you know you look at that and then
say no not not really the same but
i could come along and i could say well
you know i can write a function that
just swaps the elements
it's really easy to do that i can just
swap the elements and then i can go back
to my rule that i had earlier it's like
if it can be adapted into a duck then
it's a duck
um
you can look at that and sort of say
well you know i could go between the two
and i'm not going to lose any
information
and maybe i'm i'm you know i'll use like
my force of status or something and say
well you know actually those actually
are the same type
okay well maybe not not quite the same
type but they're an equivalent type
i can go back and forth between the two
so
that's sort of you know sort of
introduces this new line of thinking
which is basically if i have something
that can go back and forth between a dog
i don't know if i could convert a duck
to a goat and then i could take a goat
and convert it back into a duck then i
could say well the goat is basically
equivalent to a dog okay so
this is um
kind of a new rule i mean one way to
think about the rule is it's kind of an
extension of what you do in python
already like you know is is the same
object and equal it's the same value and
maybe there's some new operator i don't
know this squiggle thing here where i
claim that two things basically have the
same quote structure now i've put
structure in quotes because it's kind of
a loose idea it basically means i could
convert one to the other and back
and get back to where i started
as an example of this um here is kind of
an example
is the tuple a b
equivalent to the string containing the
tuple a b
as python programmers are going to look
at that and say no that's crazy but i
could claim that those are actually the
same because repper takes me one way and
eval takes me the other way and there's
no information lost actually the only
thing that would be lost here would
probably be my job if i started claiming
such madness at work right okay so um
but under the under the system of rules
that we're working with right now those
are the same um and you can kind of uh
kind of extend this into other thought
processes here like um
what if i had a pair with a nested pair
inside
pair a
paired with pair b like pair pc like
that
can i
can i just move the pairing can i can i
just shift it over like is that the same
as pair pair a b c like like that
are those equivalent to each other and
the answer is yes they are equivalent to
each other although the code is a little
painful to read in the in the way that
i've i've done this basically basically
you can shuffle things around
and those two things are
are equivalent because there's no loss
of information like i can convert from
one to the other and i can go back the
other way
here's a here's kind of a trickier one
um
what if i had a pair
and i had none on it
paired nun type
what is that none is kind of weird in
python right i mean none is actually
this thing that exists but there's only
one value of it none so it's a singleton
and so
um
i could i could certainly ask a question
is there some way to simplify this thing
like is there something equivalent to a
pair of a with none and
it turns out the answer is a
why is it a well i could just get rid of
the num there's a like there's no loss
of you know information there like so i
could just convert it to an a and then
if i wanted to convert it back
i just stick a none on it
i know what none is none is none so
whether i have it or not is sort of
immaterial right so so those two
those two are equivalent and essentially
you build up a kind of a set of rules
doing this um you know pair a b is equal
to b a and then you can move the pair
and then you got this
this none thing so
in some sense this is kind of a set of
typing rules about pairs
in in a slightly kind of extended
universe okay i mean you might be
looking at this saying just davis has
completely gone off the rails with this
weird equivalence rule but
it kind of works okay so
so that's that's that's one line of
thinking um about arrows basically we're
talking about arrows and um
you can put a type on it
you can put a type on the arrow and you
can start thinking about pairs of arrows
and all kinds of other things
so
there is another line of thought though
on arrows okay so let's say you had an
arrow and
i wanted to do something other than put
a type on it
what can i do with it well
one thing that you could do with it
is just change the direction
just reverse it
reversed arrows okay just take all the
arrows and and and reverse it this is
actually something really good to do in
real life by the way uh not pick on
brian brian here uh but you know just
just take like screws and nails and
stuff in your house and just put them in
the reverse way and just see if people
ask questions right okay so
so we're so we're going to reverse all
the arrows okay so imagine this scenario
alien comes down presents this magic
object
and instead of arrows coming out of it
it has arrows going into it
and then it's sort of weird it's like
once it's like this alien object has you
know the arrows coming in suppose that
you can adapt it into different things
like you can adapt it
but you can just never split it anymore
it's like the reverse of a pair it's
like it's i don't know it's like you put
things in and you can never split it but
you can you can repaint it and reshape
it and deform it and melt it
bury it and all this stuff but no matter
what you do to it
the thing is basically indivisible
it's like a permanence to it it's like
this you sort of have this shape that
looks like this you know two things come
in
and then there's like this you know you
follow the arrows but there's kind of
this finality to it right it's like one
once once the two arrows come in you
just can't do anything
do anything with it and
so the question with that
reversed arrows again is what is it
like how would you describe this thing
like okay what what are we looking at
and
maybe after a bit of study on it you
would conclude that this represents
choice
it's not two things paired together it's
a choice of one thing from two things
and so
examples are things like bits
maybe it's one or zero it's left zero or
it's right one but it's not both it's
either left zero or right one
maybe it's a boolean of some kind like
an if else kind of thing it's like it's
either true and a or it's false and b
but it is not both it is one of the
other it's either either a or either b
um
a more interesting case would be
something like a python function
we'll say you have the most just a
really simple function involving ins
return x plus two
it actually follows this same shape
maybe there's a you know an input like f
of two where you get a value and you get
a result back
okay you get a value four now you might
be looking at this and sort of thinking
like what's that
what's the second arrow i don't see any
choice in here i don't see any if
statement or anything like that well i'm
not talking about an if statement i'm
talking about exceptions
the other arrow might be exceptions like
if i put two in there as a string get an
error
so python function it's a choice it's
either you get a value or you get an
error
not both but one of those okay so
this uh this sort of line of thinking
kind of leads to some
parallel thought with the pair thing
it's like you can you can start thinking
about well okay well let's what is the
what are the rules for this choice
business this either business like
can i switch the a and the b
i i think you'd argue yeah it's like
you're picking one or the other it
doesn't really matter what order they're
listed there and um
you can also kind of shift the choices
around like is is the choice of either a
and either b or c
the same is you know just moving the
you know the ether over there and again
those are those are basically equivalent
i mean you're choosing one value and it
doesn't matter really whether you
you know decide to choose the a b first
and then choose the c you know between
that and c or go you go the other way so
so
there's sort of a certain you know sort
of similarity to what we had before um
but then you sort of get to this little
riddle okay so here's kind of an
interesting little thought okay so none
in python is something that exists
it actually it it it exists okay i mean
i can type it in the reply and it exists
okay so none is not none it's
it's this object it's none
um and this world that we're working in
is um this world of reversed era
everything got reversed right and so um
what is the reverse of none
like if i were to reverse none what are
we talking about none is something
exists that doesn't have many properties
other than existing so
um
the reverse of none
is maybe this concept of void
none are void what does this mean okay
so void
this is not a pythonic kind of concept
really but void
is essentially an a type that can never
ever exist it's the opposite of existing
none exists void doesn't exist
so a man you have a class if you try to
create it it just instantly blows up
can't exist okay
this leads to
some other rules like what if you had a
choice of either a or void
what is that
equivalent to well it's equivalent to a
and the reason it's equivalent to a
is that you can't create voids
void can never exist and since it can
never exist you can never create it and
since you can never create it you can't
choose it
it's not a valid option okay so the type
either a void is a
um just as an aside by the way
you can create things from voids
if you want to have a function that just
spontaneously creates 42 out of nothing
okay like the the
the empty parens are like void you can
do that you can you can implement the
big bang
you just can't implement the void okay
so
so that that is perfectly allowed
and so um
this leads to kind of another you know
sort of another set of rules basically
rules about this either operation it's
kind of in this universe with the
reversed arrows right you know it's like
okay and if you pair that up with the
other rules essentially you have rules
of pairs and you have rules of choosing
and
the
thing you're going to notice here is
that basically the rules look almost
identical to each other
except for the none void thing okay so
none and void are kind of you know
opposite concepts you know none exists
but void is something that can't exist
okay so
so you so you have that um
as a final kind of line of thought you
can ask um questions about whether these
what happens when these mix together
like what happens if you create a pair
and you put a void in there
is that equivalent to anything what's
that equivalent to and it turns out that
that's equivalent to void
the reason it's equivalent to void is
you can't create voids
ever not as part of a pair not in a data
class not in a struct or anything okay
void can never ever be created so
if it were part of a pair you wouldn't
be able to create that either it's it's
like a
i hesitate to say the word virus but
void is like a virus on the types like
you put that in there you can't create
them
a bonus kind of trick question is what
if you have um a choice of two pairs
but the pairs have some commonality to
it like let's say they both have an a
what is that
well you can rewrite that as a different
form you could say this is a pair where
there's an a
and then it's either b or c
there's basically what's going on there
is either choice has an a in it so you
have that there's no question about the
a the only the only question is about
the bc part so
so putting all this together you get
this kind of
this system of type rules okay this
we've written some rules and they kind
of come from different worlds i mean the
thing i think it's interesting you know
there's there's kind of the world of the
forward arrows that's the pair world and
then there's the reverse arrows and
that's the that's the either um
the the either world
and so um so let's say you work this out
okay work this whole thing out and then
um
let's say you're the one to beam it to
aliens okay we're gonna flip we're gonna
we're gonna flip the rolls here it's
like okay you're gonna give this away
um or or maybe you're actually not
enough not aliens let's say you're just
going to give it to your coworkers and
and or or maybe you publish it in a
conference or something like that okay
so you
you you work out the system of type
rules and and you're gonna you're gonna
give it away and
naturally when you give it away the
aliens and your coworkers are not going
to see it the same way they're going to
see it probably something like this
they're going to look at it and say what
is this what are you talking about is
this some kind of quiz and you're going
to say no it's not a quiz it's a job
interview question this is what we we
give our job applicants to find out if
they're 100 x or not we give them this
question we ask them what is this
okay so
that is
kind of leads to an interesting thought
experiment as well like if you were
given this with no background
information at all just out of the blue
and you were asked to describe what it
is
what is it
okay i'm gonna sit there and like study
it a bit right you know it's like huh
okay
what what what is this um after a
certain amount of coffee and maybe a
long bike ride or something like that
you might actually conclude that this is
algebra
this is describing algebra and here's
here's the rationale on that
maybe the um the the
the emoji the hands there maybe that's
like multiply and the finger is like
plus
maybe this is maybe these are describing
operators
and what you're seeing there are
actually some rules about um
like sums and products you know the fact
that you can like switch the order or
you can do the grouping you know in
different different order like that so
maybe
maybe that's what's being described in
the first part of this is kind of
multiply and divide you know multiply
and add you know kind of rules like that
maybe the um
the little arrows are like one and zero
and so what this what this rule is that
the third rule there is sort of saying
that a times one is equal to a a plus
zero is equal to a
these are
these are algebraic rules and maybe the
other rules are some other um you know
some other rules from algebra you
multiply something by zero you get zero
the other one is sort of distributing
things or factoring that kind of that
kind of that that kind of stuff so so
maybe somebody would make a claim that
this is algebra and
you would actually be correct um one of
the things that's out there is this
concept of algebraic type systems uh
this is something that you sometimes see
in other programming languages though
they'll claim that oh we have an
algebraic type system and
usually they'll throw around terms like
oh we have product types and some types
and usually what they're talking about
is you have structs and records and you
have enoms
enums would be kind of a maybe a weak
area of python or maybe a more that
that's probably a nuke like python
traditionally has not had a whole lot
with enums but it started starting to
show up but
this is this is kind of the the
foundation of algebraic type systems is
this idea that types can be
expressed in algebra now i wanted to do
one example of this
that
person just it just kind of sort of
blows my mind um
on the algebra side so let's say you had
a like a list of t's i don't know like a
list of ants of some kind
how would you describe the type of that
in this system that we formulated now as
a python programmer you might run into
this and you would just say well this is
list t
i don't know typing module or something
list t and i'm going to get super
annoyed by that and i'm in fact i'm
going to dock full points because i'm
going to say no use algebra that's not
algebra i don't know what that is that's
just it's something else okay so
so that so you're going to look at that
and say
okay beasley and okay what are you
talking about here's the line of
thinking in algebra um
maybe you use none
to represent an empty list
and in this whole system that we've
formulated none is basically like the
one object okay that it was like this
this weird
it's a singleton one is the one none is
the one it's just the one one object
okay so maybe list is one
and then
if you have a single item list maybe
that's
t
maybe t none is is
represented like that this is a choice
basically at this point it's like i
either have a choice of none
or i have a choice of a list with a t in
it
plus is choice it's not both it's a
choice it's either empty or i get a t
and then you then you can ask like well
how do i get like
how do you get all these other t's well
one way that you might do that is
through recursion
you might read a little funny but what
you're saying here is that this is okay
i have a choice of either an empty list
one
or i have a t followed by another list
it's recursive okay so so it's it's this
recursive definition of of the type
now naturally you know people are going
to get annoyed by that or like in python
we don't do recursion what are you
talking about
hate recursion
there's a recursion limit okay beasley
what are you doing recursion for okay so
if you didn't want to do recursion
there's another way to express the type
which will probably equally annoy people
but another way to express the type is
through infinite series
you can say that a list is basically the
infinite series of t to the n power
you're like okay okay what okay so so
the way to read this is like it's either
an empty list one or it's a list with
one t
or it's a list with two t's or it's a
list with three t's
or a list with four d's and so off off
to infinity okay so this will be left as
an exercise by the way how to express
this uh for like thai hinting or
something like that right okay so
so you can do it as infinite series um
now
having shown you infinite series here
here is a a really interesting
line of uh exploration um infinite
series
is actually something that one studies
in calculus class and
one one claim about calculus is that
people sort of say that calculus that's
totally useless for programming we don't
do calculus well i mean okay maybe
you're making games or something but
like for just programming there's
nothing in calculus that's useful at all
but
one of the things in in calculus is they
talk about infinite series
and it turns out that this infinite
series
actually has a result that you can that
you can compute
um
now never mind the fact that calculus is
it's like for numbers
you know has to be less than one or
something like that but but there's a
result that you can compute and being a
python programmer i'm just gonna duct
type this thing
in fact i'm just gonna write that list t
is equal to one over one minus t i have
no idea what this means okay t is a type
what is division of types what is
subtraction of types i don't know what
that is
but i'm going to continue
in my duct typing world here and i'm
going to just do algebra on it okay 1
minus t times list t is equal to one
again i have no idea what this is doing
t is t is a type okay so
but we're going to continue we'll we'll
multiply the thing out list t minus t
list t
and then i'll move it over to the other
side and then i'll notice hey that's the
same definition as the recursion
it's the same type
as i mentioned there will be a quiz on
this on this later on okay algebraic
type system okay that that is an
interesting weird strange strange world
now now going back to the um to the to
the original question though back to the
back to the symbols okay so let's let's
go back to the quiz the job interview
question
um
somebody else might look at this and say
you know
you know what i see i see something else
in this system that you've created here
what i see is actually logic
i see the rules of logic maybe the
the hands are the and operator and the
priority finger is the or operator
and i have rules of like and and or and
maybe the the arrows are true and false
so a and true is equal to a and a or
false is equal to a these are these are
statements that we know from boolean
logic maybe uh maybe this whole thing is
actually describing kind of a logic
system
and
the answer to that is yes actually no
there's a whole there's so you can view
types like a type system as a system of
logic so you know if types and code
logic
you can sort of run down this other
direction it's like type checking is
that a type of proof
are programs proofs or proofs programs
what can you instantiate that's kind of
an interesting question if this is logic
are you allowed to instantiate falsehood
you can't instantiate void that was this
that was the distinguishing feature of
void so like
if you're if this is logic
and void is the same as false it's it's
like huh okay that's that's
that's that's sort of interesting and
kind of a wild thought there
um and then you know you again going
back to the um you know back to the the
magic language here uh somebody else
might look at this
and maybe they conclude that this is a
language for describing diagrams
i would actually kind of worry about
that person a little bit because it's
you know
that might require more more more
thoughts on it but
um
having having gone through this um you
you suddenly have this question of like
what are we talking about here
we talking about algebra are we talking
about logic this arrows business what
what are we doing here are we talking
about types and
the answer is
yes
that's what we're talking about
and that's the end of this talk now
having uh gotten to that that's the end
of the tone poem part of this talk um
you're gonna you're gonna look at this
and say okay what was that okay
like what are you talking about beasley
okay so let me give you a little let me
get a little backstory on this okay and
then we'll
we'll we'll talk a bit okay so one of
one of the things that's happening in
python right now there's a lot of
interest in typing
static type type static type checking
and type hinting and all this a lot of a
lot of stuff with types
um
the the thing with types though is that
is that is a pretty big ocean
like if you look at the world of types
it is way bigger than python um there's
a lot of kind of weird stuff out there i
mean you get like if you get into the
world of like type functional
programming and all this stuff there's a
lot of stuff with types and so
um
after i had my my bike accident
so i had my fight getting back to the
bike accident uh with with broken wrists
um
i was sort of at a loss of what to do in
the morning i mean it's like you know i
don't want to just sit around my house
and do nothing and i was i was like you
know maybe maybe i'll get a they would
get a gym membership so i signed up you
know signed up for the sign up for the
gym and went over there and it's like
now i'll just do stationary bikes or
stair climber or something the problem
is the gym for me is just super boring
oh god it's terrible so
so i was over there i was like you know
i should i should learn something
i don't know i should learn about
something new something that i don't
know anything about not async io you
know like the usual stuff something
really really really really different
and
for reasons that i do not understand and
cannot explain i decided to answer the
question
what is category theory
category theory is one of these things
that you hear sort of typed functional
programming people talk about and then
usually it goes off into some really big
discussion of all sorts of terminology
you can't understand so i ended up i
ended up dropping into category theory
from like
you know just out of nowhere and i ended
up watching probably about 80 hours of
courseware on category theory and this
this talk
in some sense is a very very very very
impressionistic painting of category
theory um so a lot of the things in in
this talk what that what you know what
that is about is is actually thinking
about
i don't know maybe shapes of things like
arrows like the relationships between
objects and other
other kinds of related things a lot of
the ideas in the talk are actually very
category theory ideas like this you know
that all that madness with like the
perfect pair and like that that that's
that's
something like a categorical limit that
people talk about and this idea of
reversing the arrows and all this
all this stuff those those are ideas out
of out of category theory but um there's
also some ideas kind of floating around
that topic related to types as well um
there's there's there's an intersection
of typing
and algebra and logic and category
theory
where
you can kind of notice that basically
there's a lot of similarities in these
topics and they all kind of intersect
with intersect with each other so you
know another
you know their sort of direct
inspiration for this talk is actually
something known as the howard curry
lambic correspondent
has to do with the intersection of these
of these topics so it's kind of
interesting it's like could i talk about
that without talking about it in some
in some weird way now now as far as what
this might be relevant for python
programmers
i have no idea i i i will say that that
that exploring this has had kind of a
profound impact on how i think about
python in kind of a more nebulous kind
of
general way one of the things that it's
got me thinking about is the importance
of interactions between pieces
like apis like how do things compose
together how do features interact with
each other and stuff like that so
that's sort of interesting but i beyond
that i i don't know i think i think
maybe the interesting thing is that you
know in this kind of
ocean of types
there are other things out there
and this is an example of another thing
i mean you might encounter it if you you
know hang out with too many haskell
programmers or something so so anyway
that's the that is the the end of that
end of the talk um you know sort of
thanks for listening to that a couple of
couple things at the end i have included
a few links
that are mainly my entry point into this
like crazy topic i mean if you're
interested in looking at that category
theory this is how i entered that topic
you know there was an mit course on that
and you know there's some reading about
that um also just shameless plug the i
have a new python book coming out
it just went to print yesterday
so you can look at that i'm not gonna
say any more about that though but but
thanks for thanks for